[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello I'm Jennifer so how do you welcome
to today in chess this is a special show
that we're bringing you from the st.
Louis chess club to cover current events
in chess and of course this week our
featured story will be the candidates
underway in Berlin but we're also gonna
be talking about some other events such
as the protest League that was great the
playoffs in the st. Louis Arch
qualifying for the next round of the
playoffs re doing
oh and this is Yassir Sara Juan I'm
gonna be with Yasser and Maurice to
cover all these exciting events um
there's also the European individual
championship that's going on a big big
month for Josh absolutely it's a golden
golden period for chess because that's
you just mentioning a European
individual Championship is going on
right now as we speak one of the big
events we got the US Championships
coming up later in April just so many
things happening and let's get to it
Jennifer where are we gonna go to right
now
Oh stealing the show in the chest
headlines right now is the Berlin
candidates because this tournament is
all important it is gonna determine who
plays Magnus Carlsen for the World
Championship later this year in London
and let's see ten rounds into play
how are eight candidates are faring well
we are starting with Wesley so one of
our two American horses in the race and
unfortunately Wesley started off by
castling but I don't mean that in a good
way
he lost his first two games in
Pittsburgh he couldn't fully recover
gasa
exactly he hasn't really found his
rhythm the two early losses really took
the wind out of the sails and
unfortunately for Wesley he's currently
tied six through eight with three and a
half points from the nine years played
another player who surprised that is
Levon Aronian many picked him is a
pre-tournament favorite not only because
he was the highest rated going in well
at least invite less right and on top of
that he just had such a stellar 2017
exactly he was definitely
along with Shaq Mohammed or off Player
of the Year in 2017
he had high hopes high expectations he
ran into an incredible piece of
preparation by Vladimir Kramnik doesn't
look like he fully recovered and
unfortunately he too is languishing in
that spot six through eight for three
and a half points as well another player
who's been full of surprises for us for
a wild card some people were thinking
nor mvo the deserving recipient but
kramnik wow he's really dazzling us with
the dynamic chess and he actually
started off with two and a half out of
three taking an early lead in the
competition absolutely and how he did it
was fantastic but what a rollercoaster
ride he's been on since that beautiful
start as you mentioned two and a half
out of three look at his gorge in three
and a half from nine he's always called
one point in his last six games really
he sunk badly he's really fallen off the
pace he doesn't look like he's gonna
recover at this moment no but giving us
stories enough for the candidates
meanwhile we have Dean Moran on the
opposite side of the spectrum steady is
indeed so steady in fact that he's had
ten straight draws in fact the first
team finished in around ten was his draw
against our own Wesley so that's right
then scoring four and a half points the
first player ever from China to compete
in the candidates he came in you know
wanting to do well but when you look at
his score and his performance he's
basically drawing himself out of the
competition as you said there can be
only one and the first prize is what
everybody's playing for and he's
currently at 50% with four and a half
out of nine but really five out of ten
and we had high hopes for his to be a
cardiac and because he seems to do so
while under pressure having won last
year's candidate and also faring so well
and giving such a formidable fight to
Magnus Carlsen in their world
to match one of the highest-rated a lot
of people thought he was a
pre-tournament favorite yeah and
remember that in Moscow the candidates
tournament that he won
I believe he started with like two and a
half out of seven in the first cycle and
then he came back to have a war and
finish now he's currently at 50% as well
but he's fought his way to the 50% he
started with it there's two losses and
he was in the cellar and maybe if he can
put together another great run he could
still be in contention for the
all-important first prize meanwhile we
also have green shaken by the way these
two Russian players reach up in cardiac
and did play today and that game was a
draw okay Alexander Grisha currently I'm
still with a puncher's chance here Yasir
it was bringing together some wins in
the final round she's a currently in
third place with a five now five and a
half points and also with a lot of drama
to his result having lost in the first
round but now being unclasp on exactly
he's making a wonderful stab at the
leaderboard I actually thought it was
going to be a two horse race and
exclusively a two horse race between
Shak and fatty but this man is in the
hunt and here he is shocked mommy there
are of in second place right now
currently playing in Spaziano Cara Juana
and what a tournament he's had but
there's one man who has superseded his
tournament so far Fabiano Cara wanna
playing something pastic chess in fact
his tournament could be even as a result
could be even higher than it is right
I'm especially looking at the position
that he's ran yeah well there you see
our leaderboard with Fabiana leading
with three wins no losses and six draws
partly with a score of six they are
playing today and what a rival
game that's going on right now between
the number one and number two in the
tournament that's right because of the
tie great system here if one player is
to win this game they would have a huge
lead going into the finals final four
rounds because head to head is that
first tie break exactly
so really crucially we're gonna go over
to Maurice to talk about how Fabian au
got to where he is in this you know
crucial tournament absolutely crucial
tournament indeed this event is the most
important individual event for all the
players in this tournament except the
world champion because he's not playing
obviously they know that if they win
this one first of all they win this
event the money there is something like
ninety thousand euros then the world
championship match is guaranteed to be
another half a million dollars or
potentially more and then their if they
lose the world championship match then
they still get seeded into the next
candidates by the current rules so their
path the next couple of years as a
chance to become a world champion will
just be right in front of them and Rosie
as ever so they know how critical this
is every single move counts and it has
been an absolutely scintillating affair
so far
tremendous fights on all the boards
players just going at it we've been just
recalled by their intensity and desire
to win but one man right now stands out
above the rest and that is Fabiano
Caruana leading the tournament he got
off to a flying start defeating his
countryman Wesley so in a complex
position when Wesley made a small
mistake and boomed from here on ou took
it to implying some attacking moves
aggressive East six being one the big
move that started it all in that game
and Fabiano out to a start right away
with one point his next trial however he
had to play Deng Lorraine who has been
like the Great Wall of China in this
tournament nobody touching him he's
definitely been a fighter in the event
one of only three players in the entire
competition to not lose a single game
that game was indeed a fighting draw
with Fabiano sacrificed in exchange but
was not able to make enough of it in
compensation and they ended in a draw in
the next game I was a big time matchup
as well as it was Mahmud
I was turned to sacrifice in exchange in
a wild position of Sicilian going wild
and that game also resulted in a draw
between these two players who are
rivaling it out right now at the top
round 4 though was absolutely critical
former world champion Vladimir Kramnik
the oldest player in the tournament
tried to make a bid after playing a
brilliant attacking game one game for
the ages against Aronian but
unfortunately he tried way too hard in
this round as he has seemed to have done
in most of his games in this tournament
and Fabiano was able to pick up the win
when Vlade made huge mistakes at the end
and then Sergei kuryakin the previous
Challenger for the world title a very
difficult man to beat this was probably
the most boring game probably played in
the entire event I think he was just so
fatigued from the first four rounds he
though he had white this was just a
nondescript draw the next round
Viviano got a chance to play against
driving time to Christian Kings Indian
defense more like a Benoni
that was a crazy position Fabi had an
extra pawn was trying to make something
of it but the compensation looked like
it was maybe okay for black so Bobby
decided let's put the brakes on this
position and that game resulted in a
draw but round 7 it was back to the
wildness again as Aronian with his
chance of possibly being a contender
slipping between his fingers he threw
the kitchen sink at Fabi g4 aggressively
attacking and also avoiding drawing
lines but father's pool defense managed
to shut down the attack and he ended up
collecting a point that surged him into
clear first place in the tournament then
it was his countrymen again an
interesting game maybe some chances is
Wesley put his hand in the cookie jar
put a knight on b7 with white and
couldn't get it out without sacrifice in
exchange but good enough defense by
Wesley and the game between the two
countrymen ended in a draw as well and
it's this one will it be this one that
Fabi regrets at the end of this
competition we'll see because he had
real chances gets deliver in the second
time around and it looked like he let
her win slipped through his fingers as
they once again was able to hold him to
a draw and now still in first place by a
half a point is far
Caruana and he is doing battle right now
with second place let me tear off I
believe these are numbers two and three
in the world rightfully so they should
be fighting to see who plays against the
number one player Magnus Carlsen indeed
an epic battle as we speak and we will
see how he handles himself how they both
handle themselves as this incredible
tournament continues with another after
this one four rounds to go
Thank You Maurice and let's jump right
in to this crucial game between our two
tournament leaders of Shaq and Fabio I
have this position on the on my board
we're basically fabiana's upon down but
he's got this incredibly good active
rook on the d1 square
pinning the bishop to the rook and you
can't break the pin by playing Bishop to
b2 because this rook to d2 check which
will of course attack the King and pick
up the bishop kind of strategy of bobby
was to play this g6 move a couple moves
ago which allowed the rook to come to h7
which is so crucial yes because
otherwise rook takes East 7 Czech
followed by Bishop e3 would always be in
the air exactly exactly you get to play
check and position the discover check
what you just mentioned Jen picks up the
rook but this was a very nice idea by
Fabiana rook age 7 defending the bishop
on e7 so there's no rip takes a 7 Czech
escapes and now why again upon up has to
do something about this pin and he's got
to get his King off of the square of g2
I like this move
h4 a lot and before we came on the air
Marissa and I were looking and analyzing
a position I don't know if it's going to
be the variation that they are playing
but I like this idea of rook coming to
f7 with the idea of rook to f1 White has
to get his King off of the square G 2 so
this is just a line that we looked at
and we felt that although fabbi will win
an exchange the bottom line is at the
end of the day all the pawns are
disappearing right after rook
takes a - and we reckoned that this game
was going to be heading towards a draw
after jag and takes and Black is going
to go after this epon again in exchange
up for Fabiano but a likely draw and
that's going to be great news for
Fabiana fans because that means that
he'll keep his lead at +3 and Shaq will
remain at +2 and fabbi gets a draw with
results before they actually happen oh I
know I've done it a couple times
memorably in the run game I thought
really probably had that in the bag I
was I was calling that one I was
actually on the u.s. chess Twitter and I
I didn't say the result but I said it
was poor Fabiano it was poised to be a
full point ahead exactly and I had to
correct myself and an hour later I
remember two years ago Maurice and I
were doing back flips over in the
penultimate round of that event in
Moscow
Fabiano was winning his game against
Peter Svidler if he had won the game and
his nearest rival Sergei karyakin was a
piece behind against Levon and was
losing and we thought Fabio had that and
a champ at that tournament in the bag
and would become Challenger and 48 hours
later it felt like we were at a funeral
wake here in st. Louis but let me turn
it back over to Maryse because we do
have some results already from this
round 10 Louise yes in fact as you
mentioned that there was a result in the
game between Gris shook and carjacking
you know there was a special rule in
this competition because there were
three players from the same country
playing and on one side in the Russians
being Kramnik Gris shook and Kuryakin
and also two Americans who were playing
in the event as well so they made
special rules so that the the players
would play early in the competition and
not be able to affect the result later
in the competition and they played for
example in the last round and that was a
very smart rule indeed because you don't
want any statements to be made collusion
at the very end between players and so
these players played early and
been fighting chess in the main as the
Russians applied each other and as the
two Americans have battle against each
other this one though not particularly
exciting as Chris Chuck wasn't able to
make too much hay coming out of the
opening and so the game resulted in a
draw not great for car yakin fans
because only four rounds to go and he's
still such a ways out we should though
still with a fighting chance if the game
is a draw between my Madeira and karaoke
and uh Carwin excuse me then he will
still be within a stone's throw of first
and anything could happen as you
mentioned yes Bobby still has to go
through a murderer's row in the next
four rounds there's some strong players
who are coming after him next round he
places Vladimir Kramnik who has been
throwing the kitchen sink the plumbing
and his grandma's shoes everybody it's
been incredible the way he has been
playing this tournament it hasn't worked
out for him
grandma wants her shoes back but he is
fond of playing a lot of fighting chess
no question about it
boy Maurice I mean Vladimir has been on
a non-stop rollercoaster ride and he's
wondering when can he get off but he's
been so dangerous in this tournament
against everybody and what you were
saying Fabiano he still got that big
Vlad on his tournament schedule but we
also have another result Wesley so and
ding Lera and dingle air in 10 draws
well he really showed a lot of
resourceful news so sometimes you just
look at those fender allas but there
obviously is like a lot of fight and
some of them with some great content but
take it over to Murray's who well that
final position Murray's three versus
three rook ending we understand why the
players agreed to a draw what happened
well great content here obviously the
final position but before this it was an
interesting sacrifice in the opening
where an allowance of this pawn on c7 is
in this line which is pretty typical
black gave away this pawn and white had
to play this move King to f1 to maintain
it with any kind of any semblance of
possibility but pretty quickly blacks
pieces as you can see here it
active and why it has to figure out what
to do with the king in order to maintain
the advantage very difficult to do
anything
and immediately Wesley did the smart
thing started
aggressive opening up of the game
because obviously he's the one who's
down material despite the two bishops
you want to be dynamic and make sure
that white doesn't consolidate and after
Bishop g5 takes takes we saw this happen
and already the pawn had been regained
in the position and now you can see that
the chances are deadening rapidly after
rook to h5 Queen f6 rook d5 we see a
trade of Queens and then after 95 very
quickly this kind of position you can
already see perfect pawn structure and
that's why we can jump to the finish
line and see the final position after
many more exchanges ended up in a draw
den Lorraine has proven that he belongs
I mean clearly fantastic player the
first player from China in history to
qualify for the candidates and he's
shown hey I've lost to anybody here now
next step for him if he doesn't manage
to win this event he still has a
mathematical chance of 50% and things go
the right way with four rounds to go but
if he doesn't win he can always say look
I belong I belong and two years from now
I'll be back I am a star player the
number one player in China when the top
dozen players on the planet not easy to
defeat and he will continue to be a
rising star and a contender in the world
of chess as I need to add some punch to
his gauge so that he becomes a dangerous
threat but don't count him out everyone
who gets to this level is obviously a
genius magnificently talented and big
Laurentiis all of that no question about
it
ding lauren has acquitted himself
tremendously well he's very very young
player you're right if he comes back in
two years he'll be even more formidable
but let's talk about the format for a
second Jennifer this is the biggest
tournament of the year on the calendar
for these players
well it's a hundred minutes for the
first 40 moves 50 for the next 20 and
then 15 minutes for the rest of the game
so very luxurious fine control as we
might expect for a tournament as
important as mollifying for the world
champs there's a 30 second increment as
well so no Sun in flag Falls you know
you can't have it but it's obviously
much rare with with that increment the
money of course for the eyes fun first
place 117 thousand dollars but even more
important of course is the money and the
prestige that comes with qualifying for
the World Championship to challenge
Magnus Carlsen and I think that's you
know among the reason that the
difference between first and second are
not that great because the difference
between first and second is greater here
than in any other tournament and you
know that you could possibly come [ __ ]
right the prize money not such a big
difference but otherwise huge yeah just
being the Challenger and that also I
just wanted to say that the today in
chess show we have open phone lines so
we welcome calls I can ask us about
tournaments going on in the world of
chess in this event and tell us what you
think so there's a telephone number you
can call us and you can also use the
hashtag today in chess I believe to
contact us on Twitter as we have a st.
Louis chess club I'll be checking that
Twitter feed as well if you want to add
them we just posted a poll we're
actually asking for predictions and what
was going to have been in the match
between I mean in the game rather the
game between Fabiano and memory daraa
and despite the fact that it kind of
seems like mommy-daughter does have the
initiative we know that we have a lot of
American fans following the st. Louis
chess club because 33 percent of you
think that Fabiano is gonna win this
damn okay only 13% things that Shaq will
win and of course everybody else thinks
that it will be a draw are there some
bias statistics there I think we have
American centric audience at the moment
watching our show and here it was the
position where we thought h4 for me this
was the position we thought h4 and rook
c3 were quite predictable and in fact
the players have played quite a number
of moves down that main variation that
Marissa died that looked at more than 15
minutes ago and it's very at this moment
with these double rooks attacking this
bishop in the rook basically white has
to bail out give up the exchange but
that's a very good dark-squared bishop
and thanks to the highly reduced
material on the board after this move
takes 8 a - I don't think Shaq is
risking anything but I do believe that
fabbi is a little bit better just a
smidge better with the exchange well I'm
expecting a drive I'm really thinking
this is a 90% draw rate and that from
this particular position but among the
other 10% you go with Bobby yes that's
right my 14 month old son voted 10 times
in the fall times I think that was doing
but we do have our first phone call of
the day welcome to the show let us know
your name where you're calling from and
of course your question jack or disco
I'm calling from state New York I don't
want to get your opinion on the
Americans play and play overall in this
candidates I think it's really amazing
Souma games you see now there were long
games but this is real chest this is
kidding around these guys are really
going for it I was just wondering what
you thought what Carlotta's chances are
and the play overall cuz I think it's
absolutely amazing and I've analyzed the
games until 2 or 3 o'clock in the
morning so it's really great chess and I
hope they keep it up thank you for your
question in the observation absolutely I
couldn't agree with you more going into
the tournament
I was really really looking forward to
this event I think it was going to be a
great event you always have that that
that that fear that somehow the players
at this elite level which is going to
make a lot a lot of draws know this
tournament has been fantastic
the games have been just great to watch
easy to commentate upon I'm loving it I
think this is just going to it's shaping
up as one of the great great candidate
tournaments Maurice your thoughts on
that one absolutely this it's been real
thrill to watch these games every moment
it's a straw dropping especially the
play of one Vladimir Kramnik I mean he's
actually almost strolling the show as
Carano is playing extremely well my MIDI
Rob is playing extremely well Tingler in
super solid but kramnik has just just
said that you know what if I'm gonna go
out as the oldest guy in the field I'm
gonna go out and the most flamboyant
fashion possible and big fly we know
back in the day are you consider him a
solid player this guy was ultra
positional of course he could rip a
kingside apart with the best of them but
certainly more on the positional side
but yes I would say he sort of thrown
the Kramnik positional manual out the
window and then lit a torch to it
because the games he's playing I have
just been insane I mean insane erratic
even some of his decision-making so that
he has definitely kept us all on pins
and needles as to what he's going to do
and even this round right now against
Aronian he's doing the exact same thing
every single round looks like he came in
either with his shades of glory or a
death wish one of the two he just said
that's it I'm going one way or the other
is he thinking maybe it's his last shot
at being world champion I don't know but
he's certainly keeping it absolutely
thrilling I'd also like to make a point
last point Matt Madeira he's plus two
and his wins have been against crown
they can against Sergey Carr yakkin
kramnik win 64 moves the car yeah can
win 71 moves so he's playing long hard
fighting chess and all his games have
been pretty dynamic as well you gotta
like his opening theory he's not one of
those boring he 45 snoozefest let's play
that kind of chess every
it looks like he really wants it and he
wanted it this game but maybe he's not
gonna get it all the way but don't think
this is over with four rounds to go
my Madeira will be making a bit to try
to take first place and surpass Fabiano
Caruana the color also asked us about
what we thought the chances of Fabi win
and I think that there obviously to me
is looking at the game today and
assuming he doesn't lose or obviously
over 50% because you know you've got
mommy tariffs as the veneer is chaser
but he's gonna have to make up some
ground if he only draws today more to me
yes when the tournament yeah really
that seems like a lot you think it's
less than 50 gotta be less could win a
couple games exactly the other players
but he doesn't have to win a couple of
games it's just he just has to lose one
that's true and then the whole
tournament is changed and is possible in
the next four players he has to play
that he could just lose a game I mean
it's four routes ago though I would I
think I would at least put 50% on it Wow
I would take I mean I love Fabia I think
he's gonna win
I think his chances of winning are
greater than everybody else is probably
significantly so buddy think over 50%
well let's hope you don't jinx him with
that okay I mean coming in two days
round I mean I thought it's a two and a
half person
horse race so obviously fabbi and Shaq
in my view had the best chances of the
field to win and the other half person
in the in in that was a grecian grecian
yeah there's a direction today had a
real chance he's right against Sergei
but and the fact that Sergei drew I mean
that's really nice for Fatih is like he
says you know go out have dinner on my
account
that's really nice thank you for drawing
and keeping Grichuk beneath me now again
this is a really really big test coming
into today's game Fabiana with black if
he could you know make a draw if he had
a result here
that would have just it's great for his
chances and I think that Fabiana by the
way is one of those players who is a
very very good front runner once he has
a tournament in his grip he usually
doesn't release it and so I mean I think
mathematically we're probably being
aggressive at the 50% but I do like it I
do like that call we saw him go seven in
a row and nothing he's done in chess is
gonna rival that maybe nothing else he
ever does in chess will rival that
except becoming the world champion
everybody now says of course that's what
you got to do that's it after going
seven in a row in the tournament that
included the world champion and he beat
Magnus the first time he saw Magnus was
one will actually stop the eight in a
row quest in a game that he might have
lost that one as well exactly but this
is what I'm thinking
Fabi still got kramnik he still got car
yakun
he still has bris Chuck and who is his
final to the front and Aronian and he
still got Aronian he's got four monsters
ahead and and all and all so what are
his chances of losing one of those games
that's the question that is a good
question it's just one game one loss out
of those next four and if he draws in
Luke if he draws out and loses one and
the other player and deploy about behind
him Shaq Shaq just draws out the Raven
win a game just draws out then there's a
playoff and in whatever the tiebreaks is
we'll see but well shark would probably
win that because he hasn't lost any
games at all I don't know what the tie
breaks are because that's complicated
number of wins might be that might be
the deciding factor right and he just
like we shook in the final round which
you know not the greatest pairing
considering the fact that greaser will
be in a must-win situation possibly if
he keeps that distance right you might
be able to catch him and that would be
because right now there's a there's a
how much of a difference is there if
Bobby drawls today it'll be a one-point
different any loss is devastating right
and the question is the build up of the
pressure how do you handle pressure when
it starts the way on you we've seen
kraken show is in
credible fortitude on the pressure will
Fabi have that same intestinal fortitude
to say you know what it's my turn
none of you were gonna take it away from
me that is the question and I think that
the odds of him losing potentially
losing a game and even the odds if he
just cruised and said let me draw on my
games now you're saying my Madeira is
not gonna win anything he's not gonna
win one more game out of the next four
that's another issue so I I I think it's
more like a 40% chance Bobby maybe a
third 25 no way five twenty 25 Fabi 25
members euros okay but if we give if we
gave Fabi 40 and 25 to my Madeira of
that's that's already 65 and then 20
that's 85 and some Greek we need some
rain around something Hana exactly
including a loss by Fabi
gives the others like five percentage
somewhere in there I can't say I just I
just can't say it's too many rounds to
go to be to be saying it's dad but also
playing solo but yeah if it 45% also
sounds good I mean I mean the game
defending well he should have he should
have at least probably got that win
yesterday against big win against
England right two days ago and then
today opening was a little shaky managed
to bring it back and now no should be
able to hold I don't know I don't I
don't like writing the narrative is just
because he's winning the tournament that
he's playing so extraordinarily well I
mean he hasn't he's been fortunate to
you know he hasn't the game is crumbly
Wow
so either way just a little insight in
that because I think it was kind of
overlooked in that first cycle towards
the very end of the game between
Vladimir Kramnik and Fabiano the game
was heading towards a draw and Fabiana
made a move that was actually a mistake
he played in the move Knight c2 that
gave an advantage to two
Vladimir and offer to draw a be made a
move and offer to draw and Vladimir in
the project and the press conference
after the game said he was willing to
accept a draw and virtually any other
move except this mistake Knight c2 and
Fabiana went to on to win the game so on
little little little things like that
that game could have easily been a draw
and it was a very important victory for
Fabiano the 2014 see also you know in
that obviously played phenomenally well
but he also really got people into the
preparation multiple times and that zone
but you know take a look at it you know
the game between kramnik you and it's a
Neronian is just so fascinating if you
look at this rook sacrifice rook takes
off six that happen exchange sacrifice
and haven't get a few moves ago right so
more or less we just reach this position
when basically witness move rook on e 1
to F 1 Vladimir Kramnik
decided now was the time to sacrifice a
pawn he could have for example captured
on c5 and it would have been more or
less a pretty even position he played
the move rook e1 to f1 and after the
captures
brought back his queen and he's
telegraphing his idea he wants to play
rook takes f6 and break open blacks King
sight I really like this move D 65 by
Levon bringing this Queen over to
eyeball this f6 Knight at the same time
cut off the diagonal of the bishop
well that Vladimir captured upon Levon
captured upon and now this very sharp
move Knight g6 I didn't quite fathom
that move that move like whoa what is
the knight doing on g6 you're really not
threatening anybody or anything move on
set okay I'm gonna play Bishop e6 take
away this really great attacking bishop
which by the way has
pin the pawn on f7 to the King on GA now
the knight on f6 and pardon me tha in
the knight on g6 is under cat under fire
Vladimir captured captured and bang rook
takes f6 and the position wide open
recaptured the rook that LaVon and LaVon
just played this move d2 I may not oh
yeah you know may not be up to the late
oh we do have another move Queen g3
check but that pot on d2 is alive oh my
goodness Maurice I mean wait a minute
that font is one move away from queening
the black king under a great deal of
pressure of course what's going on in
this game Marissa this is just a
Donnybrook par for the course for
crowning this this is the kind of chess
he has played every single round anybody
who's going to play against him you know
they've got to put on their parkas make
sure you put on a helmet I'm prepared
because he's going to throw everything
at you and he's playing like he's in the
8th the 19th century somewhere playing
chess just let's just throw stuff let's
be aggressive let's attack let's see
what's going on I don't care I am going
to try to win every single game
devil-may-care attitude let's point out
by the way that comlink was a wild card
in this tournament he was chosen by the
organizers to play in the event as he
did not qualify through the standard
means some players had complained about
that some people felt like maybe it
should have been nvl who would who's
certainly one of the great contenders to
probably win it all
some even prefer to have a Nakamura in
there may be but kramnik was the choice
and it looked very good the first three
rounds like he was well he was winning
the tournament after the first three
rounds and playing that brilliant game
against Aronian but things have gone way
south ever since but he is still playing
enterprising chess he's still going for
it
raiding who cares he's ditch so many
rating points this event is not even
funny but he is still continuing
this attitude and I think he's probably
right now Yasser and Jen he's in that
devil-may-care attitude that's like you
know what I don't care you don't know
what I'm gonna do I could do anything on
the board and be careful because I might
do it against you and you know if I if
he hits it's going to be a hard hit
that's why I feel a tomorrow's game
against Bobby is going to be critical
for Fabi to make sure he's know keeping
a good eye on this guy he could maybe
just draw but more likely he probably
could steal a point IFFT Romney goes
overboard but he could also lose the
game oh my gosh yeah that's right though
Maurice I'm thinking about that scenario
you mentioned that kramnik goes kind of
bananas and that is Bobby the pole
position I'm trying to add up my 50 well
no question about it
Vladimir has brought a brand of
belligerence we just don't oftentimes
associate with Vladimir Kramnik because
we know him is such an extremely solid
and creative player who likes to grind
and push technical positions but this
event he you know he's channeling
Michael tall those inner michael tall
because he has really gone on an attack
in many of his games and he's doing it
again
I mean as you say devil-may-care
attitude and it almost looks like
there's a you know something wrong with
the chess board this pawn on d2 supposed
to be a white color pawn you know like
how does that bomb to get that they do
and it's it's one move away from
promotion and there are big threats here
Jim Bishop takes c6 rook takes f7 the
Queen will come down here for checkmate
but this pawn is is queening with a
check so if we were to play Bishop takes
c6 I'm thinking that we're going to just
queen the sky and after King h2 look at
all the focus that's going on on this f7
square but there is this nice move Queen
takes c6 protecting against rook takes
f7 is why we have to Queen
we can give one of them back and that
just stops the attack so I don't think
Vladimir is in a position to continue
with that Bishop takes c6 aggression the
quad
you know just stopping b1 okay he pulled
back well not exactly because I guess I
should take c6 there's always Queen
takes these things and again we can't do
workout seven or night of seven good you
could sacrifice and make a queen also
there is this knight g6 check exactly
right so your black has to keep an eye
so let's say LaVon should just get rid
of this Bishop let's just take that off
the board Bishop takes beat we cannot
the bishop that's the problem
oops that's a Royal fork that'll cost
black his queen so we have to protect
the square d7 we have to protect the
pawn on f7 we're gonna have to play oh
it's already been play okay very good
I was thinking I'm saying okay you need
that defensive resources rook on a5 it's
not participating now it is it protects
the d7 square and more importantly it
protects the f7 on but now white 96
check exactly you're gonna have to go
come back with the King on to the
discovered to the G file where we can
continue with a discovered check
but how would that go let's say exactly
exactly
now how can glad Amir follow up with
something might have four forces the
king at least should he go to the h7
square perhaps so you can't go to f8 now
at least but you can't go to h7 okay
because I think my idea was that now the
knight is also attacking a6 rightly so
you got you can chop that guy off but
there is still I mean it's remarkable
but this pawn on d2 it's still alive
that's true but we are thrown in Queen
g7 for the moment
you have to start with that in the
nectar Bishop e6 Queen e6 there's a
queen bee a Shack pesky yes yes so
that's very nice that's why we cannot
play the move King f8 then we have to
move not to the f8 square but maybe to
the H file ok and now if we play my plan
is what whatever minor piece captures on
e6 I want to give back that exchange 7
primal threats that's a winning move
that that just flat-out wins it means we
have Esperanto like b54 or something Hey
no it means that we can't blinking
example probably the same thing right
that same pattern that Maurice just
mentioned because you are threatening
Queen e5 check you're threatening Queen
g7 check and made we have some
potentially I'm still looking it's
definitely you know desperado Bishop g4
rook t8 you have Queen e5 track right
right so rep g8 Queen e5 check that is
really a winning move I love that
I mean Vladimir Kramnik as you saying
grandma's shoes the kitchen sink the
plumbing let's try Bishop g4 I do you
three with check if pawn takes Queen III
check and then I've got that superb pawn
and I got the idea that's the other
thing
well when you're in your golden because
as you just mentioned your trading
Queens his desk is definitely what Queen
takes III check where am i moving my
king I guess h2 h1 let me put my King in
safety for a moment so I got two pieces
for a rook but that passed pawn on d2
might be worth it might have a value of
a piece but I do that me
type stuff but I've got queenie 5 check
you've got rook g an amazing number of
sharp very - Queen e2 is sometimes an
idea because you can't play rook F 2
because of do you want Queen rook g8 and
you're mentioning ideas of Queen to e2
maybe even cleaning upon oh boy you
might have to go through this desperado
Bishop g4 right that's important d1
could get covered so white is not
necessarily fully desperate right and
I'm just on that note Maurice same thing
I mean if we if we are forced into a
queen trade and we do end up having to
play rook to d1 Oh an item d3 makes it
impossible to penetrate exactly a 93 and
your rooks can't get in an e1 and you
can get past the knight on d3 and that
Depot too far looks dead in this what a
game and some of the worthy oh really
well Nike sees that qg7 Knight f4 check
King h8 that that did appear on the
board so sorry
so after the move rook a 7 we did see 96
96 King g7 Knight f4 check King h8 so
yeah we're guess we get some booze right
chest is off to a good start yeah
absolutely
9 85 also played ok and this is where
you came up with us and remarkable
that's Bravo that's a nice move just
stopping this Queen g7 checkmate as well
as Queen e5 checked at the cost of a
piece I'm all about trading off Queens
when I'm getting attacked absolutely
it's like desperate to try to do that
but that wasn't with you this one it was
another desperado move actually that's
what we get from it f6 kind of
interesting cuz it has like some similar
properties you're saying the work on f1
can't move because of D 1 equals Queen
so you're stopping that and you are
laterally defending with the rook on a7
and you put and you're preventing Queen
e5
because well you go to creatively defend
when you're getting attacked by somebody
like Kramnik and that's why you see
players like Aronian and Fabiano defend
positions that you look at in your life
really you know yeah exactly is look it
looks terrible and let's just take a
quick gander at this because okay I mean
as we as we've been saying all along
throughout this entire tournament
Vladimir has been taking enormous risk
the problem is as you were saying you
can't take on f6 because you're allowing
the Queen to promote and what's even
worse is your threat of checkmate that
you have with rook takes h6
the Queen actually picks up this night
on h5 and defends the check on h6 so
rook takes f6 you can't even touch that
pawn you have to come up with a
different approach to the position
Maurice looks like you want to be on you
want to be the defender here or do you
wanna be the guy 6 9 f 6 hitting this
rook in the position not allowing you to
do anything right now if Bishop takes
Bishop then Knight takes rook
Anton's mate no it doesn't sorry and now
you have a rook f8 threat
oh it is that's tricky dicky you got a
queen e5 check that's a bit of a problem
as well and and your bishops hanging I
mean white is four choice in this
position so Knight f6 and I thought this
would takes Bishop made a lot of sense
but with this Knight takes piece looks
like he's doing quite well in that
position and the rooks hanging and if
you can't just float your Bishop out of
the way Bishop takes Bishop just get
that out of the way and you have to move
your rook then this Queen could end up
on e5 this Queen is tickling on g6 is
looking at f4 H this H pawn is looking
mighty lonely and the position is still
quite chaotic so kudos to Vladimir
Kramnik once again showing that he can
play this kind of enterprise and chest
to tell you if he even draws this game
I'm going to say this is one of the best
games of the whole tournament Reiji 695
rook stock on f6 and crazy play
there's absolutely one of the beautiful
beautiful games and sadly for him he's
probably he's definitely knocked out of
the chances I would say his chance of
winning this tournament are about two
percent on on a great day but he still
forced to be contended with playing
enterprising chest like this and I'm
sure erroneous thinking why are you
playing your best games against me
against LaVon that first game that one
down will go down in history for sure
and you know we had a caller earlier who
said that he was up till 2:00 or 3:00
a.m. analyzing this is he have till 5:00
a.m. it I think that's like a 5:00 a.m.
analysis doesn't it because this game is
really extraordinarily sharp and I'm
looking at rook g7 move here I was
thinking about a Queen sacrifice that
when Queen takes and Knight takes all
everything with check that the move rook
g7 does contain a little poison of its
own the rook moves to this G file where
we are hitting this pawn on g2 maybe
setting up but my goodness five queenie
5mf we know or mean age four just so
many possibilities now that things have
stabilized you got to think okay okay i
got white right I'll be okay that Knight
can just plant itself the way it is on
f6 it's on a prime square the only
problem is that white doesn't have
everybody playing in the party he's got
the bishop eyeballing that dish upon e6
and the rook wishes it could somehow
sneak in and switch around to the other
side somehow but all he's got is a
knight that's planted on f6 but 19 Queen
are known to be a tremendous force
together especially when a king is a
little bit a little bit exposed and the
black king is a very important point is
that Queen on b6 on the wrong side of
the action if you could somehow switch
sides bend upon g5 the game is over
Oh amazing but right now Kramnik
understands you cut the board in half
and the big dog is on the wrong side
over there so your
trying to defend the position with just
columns II pieces if you will
rooks are not really great defenders so
this game is still very much up in the
air an adult fight to be sure right and
you've got to really enjoy what Vladimir
Kramnik is at least trying to do and in
this game certainly is the most replay
by the way rook FA the most remarkable
thing about this game is it all started
nearly a dozen moves ago with this
long-term pawn sacrifice that created an
incredible amount of chaos suddenly and
rook f8 is on the board highly desirable
moves that you want to make of course
are like Queen g6 or Queen f4 going
after this h6 pawns just you were
talking about the big dog don't allow
Queen takes III check which picks not
only picks up upon the check that also
covers this h6 pawn so some move like
Queen h4 just doesn't work in my view
Queen takes six and that's great
so tonight eight no we actually we have
worked to h7 played and then defer
resented that Queen and Knight are the
perfect Halloween couples costume
Queenie five setting up a discovery and
the bishop is hanging you love to
sacrifice the exchange if it did you any
good but just clean up six and then
Bishop takes c6 and you're getting made
it anyway so and that position Queen c7
was a blunder that was a blunder yes
Queen well I was thinking that look why
to set up for a night d7 discovered
check picking up the Queen I thought the
Queen had to move no Luke g7 was forced
route g7 we have forced move force but
but let's get to the action crazy seven
lost in brilliant style
oh my goodness 98 this is cover check
this roof it on f1 which was playing a
defensive role eyeballing that pawn
suddenly its mate all this is a
wonderful check mating pattern that
Bishop on b3 thank you good sir we were
saying two pieces were not in the game
the bishop in the rook and they are the
baby magically cronic says wait a minute
quite the crowd let's show you how it's
done what a finale
oh my gosh this one's gonna go into the
tactics book I play like a crown Wow big
black what a remarkable game and the
woes just piling up from the bone
Aronian as he falls victim to another
extraordinary brilliancy by Vladimir
Kramnik
that's fun to get kids into chats Jonah
my finale and they'll just go oh my word
tell you you never know what you're
gonna get with a big crowd anybody play
mini plays Fabi tomorrow really has to
keep your left eye open your right eye
open and bring your knife to the table
because this guy is going to come at you
and today scintillating finish that may
be the two best games played at least
final positions in the tournament so far
can we say that the game against Aronian
the checkmate we're sacrificing the
Queen and the discovery F to mate with a
pawn on g2 g3 and f2 and a bishop on e4
when do you ever see that construction
right you just never see that
construction this game how often do you
see this construction night on e8 right
generating mating ideas like this I mean
he's just absolutely original stuff
absolutely brilliant brilliant player
although you know something you know
he's been funny in his press conferences
right he's been brilliant conferences
he's always winning Oh better I could
have played six other moves and still be
okay and you
right what you're saying they're very
optimistic guy to be sure and he played
with that kind of optimism in a land
today as well and that's inspired great
tweets including one by Costa comparing
a Kramnik post-game analysis close to
kaput ski yes the I am and also the
writer from California he he says it's
like cram splaining as opposed to
mansplaining
where you know a guy acts like he knows
everything
exactly cram flamey of course is just
well I'm totally winning that's an
instant classic you have to make a
t-shirt you need the cramps playing this
game this game was was phenomenal and
another nice one was a fire coming into
the house a cartoon that someone posted
there's a fire it's creeping up on the
chessboard and panic this is I'm winning
you can't get out of the other window
right the fire is burning down the house
well I'm yeah I mean because of all the
things that you've been saying about
what some of the great games that have
already taken place we're here on this
today and cheshire show I think that you
know it for the near future we're gonna
have to take a look at the best games of
this tournament and do some recaps of
those those rounds that we have missed
because we have some remarkable games
this has been great
wait stop what would you give you would
have to give chronic swaying in the in
round three against huronian his best
game right just far far it's just been
phenomenal day and what game other than
that one beats the game we just saw
today well again the Fabiano the Fabiano
kramnik that game was just a roller
coaster ride with both players having no
wasn't winning chances okay so so yes
and cronic made a huge blunder the way
Aronian did here right as a matter of
fact to allow this 98 Aronian though i
had to play bulwark the g7 and shut down
what the action happening here although
it does look like there's going to be
something happening on this square as
bishop seems to be hanging on the e6
square but don't forget the d2
lots of craziness but it's clear that
chronic is more than okay right now in
this position but again you mentioned
kramnik yet again yes yeah no problem
he admitted three of the best games of
the entire tour one of them he lost that
he should have drawn this one may have
been a draw as well but again he's just
showing so maybe he's gotten his win
back getting those two out of three
points but he's showing that all eyes on
Kramnik as the the star who's not gonna
win the event it seems but what early
player in this event what about that
extraordinary game Levon versus Fabiana
where Levon sacrifices out of the
opening with g42 pond sacrifice and ends
up a rook down but maybe it was a draw
just a very end battle as well but you
know you mentioned he has that if
Aronian wanted to draw in that game he
could have backed it off and just made
the draw pretty directly this is really
really wonderful unfortunately I think
we're gonna have to take a commercial
well think about that smothered work on
h7 which really just functioned as a
pond allowing 98 it's wonderful back
rank drip it's just fantastic but I'm I
would just turn to our audience and say
you tell us what you think of the best
games after well this 10th round because
there's been some great great
donnybrooks that's what I call us after
the break or hashtag us during the break
at today in chess we'll be back in a few
[Music]
as the st. Louis chess club celebrates
its 10th anniversary the US
Championships returned to st. Louis for
the 10th straight year
this April America's best players
descend on st. Louis to play for the
country's top honor Wesley so and Sabina
Pfizer will be defending their
championships as they face an all-star
field
don't miss America's best battle it out
at the st. Louis chess club celebrating
10 years of promoting teaching and
playing the game of chess for tickets
and more information go to st. Louis
chess club org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome back to today and
chess where our first show of the week
started off with fireworks and a
stunning finale and cram dates a game
against Tyrone Yan where 98 really just
caused the ripples of excitement
throughout the whole chess falutin
drawing in some new fans no question
about it what a thrilling finish that
was I'm looking at our key matchup of
the day Jen in the game between Shaq and
fabbi and they've just well they've
reached this position some time ago that
I've been reflecting on this position
the last move of Fabiana was this move
rook d5 I really thought that Shaq was
simply going to capture this pawn on a 7
and then after move like king f7 setting
of recapture of the e5 pawn I thought
well it's going to be a draw instead
Shaq decided that well he wanted to play
on he played the move Bishop d6 and
after rook III eyeing the potential of
ganging up on this pond with rook on d5
coming back then White's king could get
hurt harassed the game continued check
and fat pardon me Shaq played the move
b3 b4 we're now at this current position
with the rook as expected coming down
here to g3 and I think White's King is
gonna have to go for a little walk here
King g4 rook takes pawn Shaq king f4 and
you get a position where it's two rooks
versus rook and Bishop and I still think
we're in a draw but I'm kind of
preferring blacks chances now that
White's King has been you know forced
out of this nice little cave that it was
in on the h3 square yeah the pawn trades
benefit you because it leaves over the
lines open for the rook precisely you
know you actually said that you prefer
rooks I do
some moves go so you kind of anticipated
this exact words I think some of the
people watching online were more
thinking about seeing the king of the
pond and the bishop and getting a little
scared
right visually yeah you're anticipating
something like this so interesting to
see that difference in judgment from
somebody perhaps looking with computer
and not as strong and then somebody with
that experience yeah and I and again I
mean I do think that a draw is by far
still the more likely result but I think
that what dangers there were in the
position for Fabio basically passed and
we'll see what happens but I'm saying
that I prefer black I just I thought
that this bishop really did belong way
back here on f4 where it would have
defended the pawn on e5 defended the
pond on g3 and allowed perhaps King g3
and King g6 losing that g3 pawn and also
by the way quite importantly visit the
Queen side pawns the a7 and b4 pawns are
still on the board generally in in in
general that favors the players with the
rooks when you're playing against the
rooks you want as many pawns swapped as
possible that's why I thought what back
here I did anticipate right here that
this Bishop was going to capture this
pawn on a7 they're thereby reducing all
the chances that are going on and the
position of Bishop takes a seven King
let me just put that move on the board
again this is this is the line I had
anticipated
began going king f7 white will lose this
pawn on e4 but it's three versus one
likely the before be pond will be lost
as well that a draw you know even if you
just had Rick and Bishop and two pawns
on the Kings side with a bishop on f4 I
don't think there's any losing chances
in that position for white but the way
the game has gone has in my view allowed
Fabiano to continue the game with
chances we might be in for a long
I don't like the games as me exactly and
it's not a coincidence that two of the
older players in the tournament I refer
of course to Vladimir Kramnik and Levon
Aronian this is a fourteen round a 14
mile event double round-robin and that's
a marathon even the world championship
match and we're used to it more rest
days than we're used to it shouldn't
even think that a little bit the level
of preparations so high in this type of
competition absolutely but the world
championship match itself is only 12
games but over to you Maurice what have
you got for us well it seems like ages
ago as a matter of fact is we have a
position where the point where kramnik
won a game for the ages one that will be
remembered certainly put in his best
game collection and thanks to our
friends over at chess 24 we've been able
to bring up this board and it was this
game against Aronian went after h3 he
played the move route to g8 crown make
signaling that he had a big attack and
he was going to use it against Aronian
he this wolf King H one night h5 and
after c3 g5
very aggressive Knight takes g4 in the
pond
steaming down the board it took a couple
of moves trying to chase him backwards
and after g3 and this trade looking to
trade Queens in the position and he said
I'll have none of it I'll drop my Queen
back and after age four c5 this is where
the mistake was made with Queen c4 to
drop back to d3 queen b5 check and now
the attack started f5 Bishop g5 Sakon
exchange takes place move f4 and the
attack was in the royal queen drop back
no move your queen out of the way and
now the King had been ripped apart and
then this monster move
rook landing on the d3 squared and after
rook to d1 now Bishop d5 the Queen
getting ready to sneak in on the e4
through p4 square mates abounding and
after the move f3 give me that and then
the final beautiful finish after Queen
e2 how often do you see a queen get
pinned on the e-file only to force the
guy to resign after g2 just an
incredible incredible game as the caller
said you can stay up many a night you
can think about it's very next day what
a game to c1 for the Aged
kramnik having won this game and then
winning yet again today against the same
hapless Levon Aronian Levon one of the
great guys in chess and he has made it
his stated mission to become world
champion he says other than that I
there's nothing else for me to do this
has been my dream for me being a young
man but now it looks like he will have
to wait again two more years to get a
shot at getting that dream to come true
love it more even in that final position
I really like that if f2 king takes you
two you can make a night with you one
right it could be the exact mirror image
double-check at that right well night
moon like LaVon has been channeling his
inner kisser it's because a risky you is
losing some of the most famous games in
chess the mortal game and another game
real evergreen and these game these
losses I want to say bye LaVon have just
been incredible I mean they they you
could write entire books about those
results because in order to have a lot
of these brilliant sees you need
somebody to be good but not too good
right they defend to well they find like
some kind of sideline it means that they
don't release a long struggle right
right yeah whereas if they're good it's
tight it's interesting but then somehow
they're sometimes a beautiful finish
that's miss absolutely and you don't
often see it at this like 2700 plus
level the 98 that's why it's such a joy
to the whole we've been talking about
Abby's winning chances but what about
his road ahead
there was a murderer's row yeah well
look he's gonna be facing what
you'll have Lattimore kramnik with the
white pieces tomorrow thank goodness for
that because Vladimir has been doing
some amazing things then in round 12 he
ha black against a potential rival in
Sergei Kerrigan and white would live on
they'll finish the tournament with
potentially crucial in the final final
round and right now it's a half a point
that bleeds so that so that's incredible
all horrible flying around for Fabi it
couldn't be worse not only dudes equally
with black but he's gonna play somebody
as long as he has a point distance
between them motivated exactly we'll
play all the way to the finish but what
about Shaq's road ahead Jack's heard
ahead let's take a look at that well
he's pleased Wensley so with black I
mean you actually kind of have to love
that pairing because Wesley had might
not push his hard for white knowing that
he's out of the tournament
yep and then he gets two whites in a row
against ding Murron and Alex agree shook
but that final round pairing also not
amazing he plays Vladimir Kramnik with
black and as we can see from this game
anything happened with Vladimir and I
don't think he's gonna take his foot off
the pedal in the last round but still
not as bad as Bobby's road ahead in my
opinion because I think just the fact
that Bobby's playing against somebody
who might be able to win the event in
the last round with a win yes that's
that's everything especially for a poker
player like Rijo he knows it's all or
nothing precisely and we have a very
special guest with us in the studio the
founder of the st. Louis chess club who
must be very excited about all of the
the great things happening for st. Louis
players this week not only is Fabiano
Khurrana meeting the candidates right
now but we also the same was
Archbishop's just made the final four
for the protest League last night it's
here in this club and then on top of
that we're also in the final four is
hello
absolutely st. Louis University with the
coach Alejandro Ramirez also from st.
Louis leading that and leaving his team
in the final four so along with
perennial favorites Webster University
also from the air they absolutely and
here he is Rex Sinquefield seamless
Chess Club founder with Maurice Ashley
well I imagine his wildest dreams he
didn't realize all this was gonna happen
with chess when he decided to have this
little chess club here in st. Louis but
Rex you must be thrilled the action
always happening it seems no matter what
the season there's it's amazing what
chess is happening around the world and
here in st. Louis it's amazing
especially the last few weeks and course
the best thing to happen is we have the
three best commentators in the world
back on the air from st. Louis I mean
the three best commentators in any sport
in the world and I keep saying that
publicly because I want someone to
challenge me
no one will challenge me because
everyone agrees appreciate those kind
words we certainly try to put on the
best show we can Rex you've got to feel
really good right now for Fabiano
Caruana he's he's a local boy and just
lives a few blocks away I believe
Marilyn I'm hoping somebody says what is
the world champion live I want to say on
Maryland Avenue oh we got four more
rounds this one and four more to go
you must be entertained by watching this
time entertain but I'm always a little
bit of anxiety you know I have to
confess to anxiety this morning when I
got up I heard Jennifer walking walking
down the steps and watching the game ago
boy this is the game he's got at least
all this was a big one today he's got
four more big ones I know Mike for you
you know you talked about the old guy
inside of me a crime they eat not so old
no he's playing some really enterprise
in chess
brilliant game today I think Viviano I
hope he's not offended but I think he
has nerves of steel and I think he has
ice water for blood he just doesn't seem
to panic in the most difficult
situations you know he seems to be
really solid and steady all the time but
absolutely and he's gonna be also
fighting for his title in the US
Championships ranked as Wesley has it
right now was they took it from him
right in previous year you must be
looking forward to think it's Pape all
those what a couple of weeks of chess in
st. Louis no it's come that's some of my
favorite times the US Championship the
same field cup I get to stay here over
the weekend for one thing which I
normally don't get to do
hang out with you guys in just
incredible and in with the archbishop's
making it to the final four that's
that's got to be incredible that's
incredible in st. Louis University in
the Final Four again yeah there's just
so many good things going on you wonder
how it all happened well we certainly
appreciate you getting ready for
Cardinals to get into another world oh
let's not talk baseball please you know
we get into fights on that one way
inky's by the way how murderers row
lined up you guys I've heard a round
those guys I heard you guys have a crime
problem in New York we're to save his
big city in America okay
sure okay your your thoughts about the
World Championship gonna be in London I
know you want it to be in st. Louis I
definitely would like to have one in st.
Louis sometime but right now as I
understand it Vijay and aegon own the
rights to it and they own those rights
for four or five more years
that's contractually sound now with all
the difficulties fides having anything
to change but it's going to take a
change for them for somebody to be able
to be forced to come and approach us
that's what I have to happen we can't on
our own initiative we can't undo
anything and if you hope we'd listen we
listen to Italy we listen aggressively
way would you be willing to commit that
you if especially if Fabiano for example
or Wesley or Nakamura you and I would do
whatever yeah do whatever closely that's
the kind of sponsorship we love and
belief in chess in America thank you so
much thank you and enjoy the rest of the
games thank you so much Thank You Rex
just a quick shout out because I just
inform our audience that the very first
official World Chess Championship match
between steinitz and super tour rex
where was a plate it was played at about
17th and Locust here in st. Louis
it was in 1886 at the harmony Club which
was a Jewish social club there still is
a harmony club in New York but there's
not one in st. Louis anymore but there's
a different building there and we've
contacted the owner we're trying to get
permission to put up a big drape big
flag saying what happened on that site
in 1886 and by the way happy birthday Oz
in advance Saturday thank you for that
Rex Wow well it's brilliant seriously
it's great to have you here on our today
in chess show and Wow this is just it's
been a thrill this is great Jennifer
coming up very soon you know we
encourage you guys to um consider a trip
to st. Louis to see all of this for
yourself in fact the world chess whole
team's gonna be unveiling three new
shows on April 12 so you'll be here just
in time to see them so very and last
night we had the ping I was here any
more yeah that was finishing but that
was the designers combining the world of
fashion and chess together
that's right and Fabiano Khurana
actually was involved in that promotion
which is like just so exciting
he's such a down to earth guy in between
qualifying for the World Championship
he's doing you know chess and fashion
collaborations it really is a very
impressive to see that we have to say
who who actually won the competition our
colleague sporting that new tie - yes I
had to buy this time at the last minute
because I'm in my haste to get the heck
out of New York with all that snow
coming down
I forgot all my ties so yeah
unbelievable is like what what the heck
I got a rival yes I'll be shopping some
ties will bring us back to reality here
because we got this huge game still
going on going we're thinking it's a
but we're also thinking that fabbi has
the better chances of the two players we
just saw a series of well capture first
of all and now this check has been
played by a B I'm looking at the line
the King's going to g5 now we really
don't want to see that King coming to
the h6 where where the in combination
with the rook of the bishop the King is
very offensive but there is this nice
defensive resource in the position for a
B which is rook f7 and I think that that
just basically kills any attacking
because don't forget there is a rip g3
check which could strand the king yes so
what's going on so if a six topping or
few three e six doesn't stop rookie
three it does defend at the square g3
but I could still change because I've
got this really thick right so let's go
the other way maybe trap take the bishop
and then put them behind the bath bomb
right do 467 Bishop take c7 work III and
get the rook behind or do we throw in a
check first mm-hmm sorry the rookie
three King f6 yes so we see some
position like this that could occur on
the parole board promising for does it
eyeballing this pot I notice that on the
left side there's a chess engine that
just went straight like the most natural
move and a threat of a seven and Bishop
e5 are both so let's let's let's check
our variation there's qg6 and then
that's just that just looks bad right
away right because we've got this dual
threat Oh after e6 I was like oh okay so
looking at
we're looking at saving look at seven
yeah we got 76 he six top 43 track which
was like mating yes now we're cat five
check doesn't work out thinks of King z6
right same story
yeah same story and that just looks bad
exactly there we got this great thanks
so what other I think it's just simply a
capture right you've got a capture on e7
and then after Bishop e7 b7 to start you
think yeah maybe it's time to do
something like that okay your your king
is now stomping the epon but after king
takes now your rook is going to be and
your rook is gonna have to keep the
h-bond at their locker you can't stop
over them so let's see did I do
something wrong here am i under
estimating Maurice am i under estimating
the threats out that that are being
faced rook f7 seems like a move he's 66
and by the way we're got seven ones
played okay really okay so we're now we
do have how about this one how about
check the idea is if you take this pawn
I wanted to take the bishop so you can't
take my rook with check that's the work
takes working this way and then I have
rook takes and I'm pretty sure I'm close
to a draw now right after rook f6 I'll
play rook here and I won't get made a
hit on the back rank but I'm picking up
a pawn yeah that looks like a draw but
White's on the sunny side of the draw
which is kind of funny
it was also played that looks like a
dead drop so this is the position that
were in everything and maybe this is the
important move I didn't realize the
activity of whites King was so powerful
that it's going to require a bailout
where we return the exchange what if we
played it worked 87 Bishop e7 and then
instead of I think we tried q g7 does
King I didn't do any better just so that
you don't you don't have a check when
you come in to f6 King age 7
I'm saving myself a move a tempo which
could be pretty important
could you were playing Bishop f6 with
check followed by e7 run whereas now if
you play Bishop f6 I you don't get your
king in I think that's the big
difference yeah I think I need I need to
keep that square as an important bridge
but okay if I come back with my Bishop
idea of King oops
scuse me my arrow King f6 and e7 now
maybe you will have to move your king
too so if you said I think f7 which was
kind of my idea I wanted to be able to
guard the precisely a75 I mean oh I was
gonna start with rook 35 jack in that
line just to stop yeah whatever it's not
important what Maurice was saying well
Maurice is saying that hey look I mean
white could snap off this pawn and then
make a draw and this type of a an ending
again that a pawn is such a crucial part
of whites
winning attempts you lose the e pawn I
don't think there's any further attempt
so we're thinking the rect xe7 Bishop
takes east seven but maybe it's your
very precise move King h7 that keeps the
draw in the hand for four fabbi and
again we can't emphasize enough how
important it is for him in this
tournament victory success not to lose
this game all the variations were
looking at and of course with the
precision and endgame technique of these
players being so phenomenal like if
we're looking all these lines and
they're ending and draws chances are
it's gonna end in a draw oh for sure you
know yeah I felt but that was the moral
Moses can you validate that our analysis
this sound yes is indeed sound and
excuse me this should be a draw which
sets up a very interesting situation
again you know the pressure bills it
looks like he's getting closer and
closer to the finish line but since he's
not definitively knocking out the
opposition he's also keeping them
too close for comfort if you will and
although Fabi will maintain a half a
point lead on the field with a draw
today he still got four hefty rounds to
go and that means that it's all to play
for
with so many possibilities still
remaining in phases the mercurial of
Vladimir Kramnik who has just been
painting either a masterpiece or a
disaster every single round you don't
know which one he's going to bring
tomorrow in round 11 car yakin who
famously beat Fabi in the last round in
Moscow to knock out his chances that's a
huge rivalry Levon Aronian right now
probably is not too motivated to play
but with the white pieces
anything could happen there and again of
course the final round against Rich Jerk
who will be still within a point of
Fabiano and could make he maintains that
will be playing for it all in the last
round so the road ahead for Fabiana
Khurana not necessarily a rosy one but
what could you expect with four rounds
to go against these monsters some of the
best players on the planet he will have
to prove himself and that he is indeed a
worthy challenger to the great Magnus
Carlsen well there you have it I mean
quite a road but having said all of that
how sweet it is to be to have a half
point lead going in and they say that
extraordinary opposition and could you
just remind me the current position have
we seen the movie at 7 we did see the
moves work at 76 okay that is actually
on the board okay yeah and we were
predicting that rook takes could very
well be a general fan exactly I I think
your your line is actually the best one
that we've found so far this looks like
a very good defense by Fabiano King age
7 that helped me with the King on f6 in
the rook and I five right that's an
amazing construction or b5 baby check
King and surprise I'm a big Bobby Otto
fast
patterns as well and that's a pretty
nice one yeah but we were expecting the
bishop to come back our main line was
this Bishop to c5 move and we thought
what was it that we thought here yes
King g7 and if we take this pawn then we
neutralize completely the e6 pawn with a
check in King f6 and fab E's at the
finish line for a draw there but we've
got some other great news coming out of
yeah tell us about the playoffs of the
protest League than chess common yeah
that's right well we have a bit of
protest League finals are coming up the
live finals are coming up in San
Francisco in last night the st. Louis
Archbishop's in the quarterfinals faced
the Minnesota Blizzard to various starts
that it seems the Minnesota Blizzard has
one of the most famous jazz players in
America right now John Bartholomew was a
very popular streamer kind of capturing
some of that eSports audience as well as
Andrew Kane the bullet legend so a very
star-studded team there but the seamless
Archbishop's did take them down
qualifying for the playoffs ie in San
Francisco we had yarrow and far leading
the Archbishop's in the final score they
played 16 games I believe between the
two teams and how did the good st. Louis
finish the match I know they were at
eight at one particular moment because
Alejandro Ramirez and I were following
that last or the following the games
that contain or I say that's right and I
know that the minute gimme a it was
actually a st. Louis that was rallying
right just looking find the the final
final standings there but anyway another
thing is they're gonna be playing
against the chain do pandas in the
semi-finals okay over in San Francisco I
mean it really will be an incredible
finale I'm actually gonna be in San
Francisco that weekend for the finals
and I'm also doing an event at the
Oakland Museum so and who are the stars
for the chain to who
yes oh gosh the pandas I wanted to say
before you get into that though that
Fabiano carolina is playing for the
archbishop she won't be in the finals
because he's gonna be playing in Greg
day well he was part of the team he
plays yes Anthony he actually went eight
Oh in the Super Saturday competition and
is holding a advanced Faviana referring
to the street they sing field cop 7o
street that's did that and so he made a
huge contribution to the archbishop and
that was one of the things that actually
gave him draws in the match last night
against the minnesota blizzard results
like that for the pandas you've got a
lot of star players including you yummy
and we chow
we also have one of the top female
players in the world why new Miwa and
one of the top women players in the
world also plays for the pandas actually
you get a bonus for putting female
players on your team so i that team is
definitely one to root for as well
that's when Jinju a grandmaster herself
exactly and like it's very powerful for
them because when they put her on the
team they could have a higher average
rating so a formidable team I mean
honestly I think there's a good chance
that the team that wins that match will
win the favorite in the finals the other
two players are the Lu Ghana turtles and
the Armenian Eagles and no hard to root
against the you all right being a
Philadelphia
yeah a New Yorker I didn't know who to
root for in the Super Bowl so I rode it
for neither but who knows who knows to
the Eagles I'm ready
Cowboys I did shake - what Eagles
because you know as a Giants as a New
York fan we can't like anything to the
north in Tom Brady and the Patriots
although we must say you know you guys
finally joined us as the only team to
beat the Patriots and to beat Tom Brady
and Belichick the dark side in a Super
Bowl but we still we still won up - but
in the meantime back to the charity news
breaking news we do have a draw in the
game between Caruana and meminger of
that game has to included it was gas
line and it was indeed that line yes sir
as we point out here the movie 6 was
played and after route to d5 well I'll
just put it here route d5 king g6 rook
takes these things and we went into this
ending the rook after rook to e4 goes
into a simple rook and pawn ending which
they just kind of mechanically made
these moves so that they can show to us
that it is indeed a draw after a couple
of checks again five takes check and
rook have six and King on King right and
definitely nobody can say well why don't
you fight so a draw
puts Bobby a half a point lead ahead of
Madeira where were we were before this
round started and that is a draw except
for bottom a crime and creeping up the
list going to four and a half with his
victory and sending Levon tumbling down
at three and a half but still look at
that top that top is very close back yes
it certainly is
and
again I I do see it as a two and a half
horse race the two players Sergei and
being at 50% could still have a shot I
mean we've been mentioning four big
games to go
if Sergei or Dean could put together a
streak they'll be back in the fray but
at this moment Vavi
dodged a very very big challenge today
black pieces against his closest rival
Shaq and he's looking good look at that
score though one loss at the top just
imagine a loss one of those top players
and a win by anybody else right so if
both of them somehow lose Fabiano a
moment zero if we're not expecting that
to happen
but it could very easily happen given
the competition they have and they stay
at six and a half and six grishnack wins
or Kuryakin wins and ding Lauren wins
and this whole tournament is a
completely different story that's the
the nature of the beast in chess
tournament one loss could upend
everything and how tight the field still
is closely bunched after ten rounds of
great chess a thrilling competition look
at this Vladimir Kramnik as a result I
mean if you just look at it just ones
and zeroes and we'll tomorrow he's
battled against Fabiano piranha chromic
plain black another decisive game in the
end that is a game that could blow the
whole tournament open because you
mentioned two and a half horse race but
if I be work to have an accident it
could blow open the event right you know
that's why about 50% might just be a
little bit on the aggressive side but
you know babbys been playing good chess
I mean he's been quite consistent I
think the most consistent player
actually has been Shaq but having said
that Abby hasn't made that many mistakes
and this in this tournament he's been
really good with black I mean
essentially two of his victories were
with black but having said that - I
really like this play with the white
pieces they'll be up against wider Marik
Ram Nick will have black and that will
be a fantastic game what wins the
tournament I'm thinking I thought Plus
was gonna definitely wins three plus
three might get you a tie but then we've
got to go through all of those tie break
scenarios I believe the first tiebreaker
is the heads up duel now that Shack and
fabbi have drawn their game that means
two draws between them I'm not sure
about that that either what the check
that it might still be most wins would
absolutely be ashamed because I think
head-to-head duels should always be
first sorry always but barring a
playoffs head-to-head is absolutely
something you should consider although
in the case of my metier of and Fabi two
draws that's right that's all saying the
first type race so that time would be
even out the window and then wins would
be in fabi's no would mean fabi's paper
because because memories your Arva would
have to win to tie Fabi that's unless
Fabi loses to come back to tie with him
in which case probably would still have
most wins to get to the same +2 score I
don't know what +2 is gonna make it I
have a feeling +2 is not going to do it
this doesn't seem right I think there's
there's potentially a surge especially
that 50% group or even grish cook maybe
pulling off another rabbit and grabbing
another win in their in his next four
games right so plus 3 what are the odds
of plus 3 winning it that's a good
question I think that's better than 50%
okay but +4 for sure would win I think
it's got away unless unless we keep
seeing more than crazy that we've seen
in this tournament yeah I did check I've
answered your questions yes please
first of all the Minnesota was four
against the artificial was actually six
to ten so actually huge victory okay so
then the archbishop's really after a bad
start because they're not hiring and a
half two and a half after the first four
games they came back big time to win
them and their board for scored 50%
their bottom boards were 50% at 2100
player against some
yeah it's maybe 20 but a 2100 player mr.
Chen proved themselves while playing
against some very strong competition 24
hundreds in the mix and still scored 50%
so that was very nice for them to to get
to points where they may not have
expected it very good and it does look
like it's the first one had the head as
Maurice prefers and the second one is
most wins in most ways yeah and then
Sanne
Herberger and in the I think in the
unlikely I think it's actually
impossible almost now but if all of
those work to be split then it would go
to a playoff okay it's very unlike so
that's gonna create like diversity
exactly if there was a lot of draws and
only a win by each player then you would
imagine a scenario with a playoff but it
seems almost impossible in this front of
end right
but that crucial Carolina grisha final
round game well it's been so fun to kick
off the today in chess was such a
incredible round yasser not a lot of
drama in terms of the standings we're
kind of at a standstill
but that kramnik game wow yeah no
question about it the tie that was a tie
from six to eight that's been resolved
thanks to Vladimir is victory and I was
just going to say that it's just so much
to talk about there was Paco
they have oh he had withdrawn from the
European Championship that's a big story
we'll have more on that tomorrow but we
can't wait for tomorrow and these next
four rounds I think we're just gonna
have so much thrilling chess to discuss
oh it's such a blast to be back with you
guys I kind of preview of what's coming
up in a couple weeks at the US
Championship but Maurice your final
thoughts on today in chess well my
thought about this whole tournament is
this position is representative of
what's been happening King on King
battles all the way to the end very few
nondescript drawers grandmaster drawers
you call them they are playing for
everything this is one of the
they consider it not the most important
tournament and they've been talking
about for months and months the whole of
last year this was on the minds off
these top players and those who
qualified know this is a life changer if
you win this event so you're going to
see blood on the board and we have been
seeing it and even when there's no blood
the players have given it their all
blood sweat and tears and looking at
each other with respect
after finishes like this one so we have
to respect the geniuses that they are
and the fact that they're giving us so
many thrills to talk about it's been
amazing and we've got four more runs to
go well today in chess is going to be
tomorrow in chess and we'll be here to
call the action because it's just simply
where it's at thank you yes of course we
always welcome your participation so
hashtag us at today in chess or call us
tomorrow but we can't wait to see what's
gonna happen in tomorrow and chassis yes
absolutely well have a good afternoon
everyone
[Music]